[Music]
the kobit 19 vaccine now starting to be
distributed among the community in
phases but
how quickly will you get that second
shot christian quesadas joining us now
in studio with answers that's going to
have a lot of people paying extra
attention christian
that's right denise well we know the
covet 19 vaccine is administered
in two shots to have its full effect
although the distribution is slowly
underway
the window to get that second shot will
be fast
it's a vaccine most americans are eager
to get but the cobit 19 vaccination
rollout from the federal government
has been rocky what we're seeing in
southern nevada is
some delay in getting vaccine to the
state
and also some delay in getting vaccine
administered two patients according to
mark khan
unlv is dean for the school of medicine
about 60 percent of the available
vaccine has been used
right now pfizer bioin tech and modern
vaccines are the only ones approved
by the food and drug administration over
the next couple weeks so it's expected
that we're going to have
emergency use authorization for several
more vaccines
those being made by other big
pharmaceutical companies like
astrazeneca
and johnson and johnson a person needs
to wait
21 days after getting their pfizer
vaccine to get the second shot
while the modern vaccine requires 28
days for waiting for their second round
you get your first dose of vaccine
that primes or gets the immune system
ready
and then with moderna four weeks later
with fives or three weeks later
you get your second dose which really
boosts the immune system
the two-step process is part of the
governor's two-lane plan to get the
state vaccinated
residents over 70 years of age will go
first as well as the public safety
according to their plan
even after two doses of vaccine
it's still theoretically possible that
you could transmit the virus to others
well remember that you need to get two
shots of the vaccine in order for it to
be fully effective now even then
health officials tell us you should
still practice social distancing washing
your hands
and using a face mask because the
vaccine is only
95 percent effective there is still a
small possibility
to catch the virus christian casadas 8
news now